I have countless cases of what I
considered impropriety in the white
house that I brought to the chief of
staff because I thought the way he
engaged with women was dangerous wow
this is I mean we know these facts the
patterns have laid out and now this is
something that's not just speculation
it's not just allegations it is a jury
of his peers deciding that he did this
wait you brought to Mark Meadows the
chief of staff or other Chiefs of Staff
incidents that you witnessed of Donald
Trump behaving in inappropriately with
women I did as well as a former White
House Press Secretary Stephanie Grisham
and others the broader story with these
major allegations against Trump follows
this pattern
we hear one allegation
and Maga rallies around Trump and most
Republicans do and say it's made up and
then we get more allegations that now
start to become a pattern and it becomes
much more difficult to say that it's
made up